yesterday I did a rap on the air about
Josh ratings new song about animals who
have been rescued a very beautiful song
so yeah this is the Sun so you got to
hear this one so my wife was so moved
there was a woman who works at North
Shore Animal League hadn't heard it but
heard about it
so Beth contacts Gary and says Gary
would you please send me a link so that
I could have a copy of what Howard said
about Josh raid in and the song and
animal rescue for Gary does that but he
sends her a link where that rap followed
immediately by I'll suck your ween Kerry
doesn't like you know Gary kind of just
half-ass his stuff you know what I mean
you know what you know what I mean he
doesn't now you probably never even
listened so so I said what happened she
goes well I forwarded to the North Shore
Animal League people and they were in a
meeting and so they didn't know they
don't know when the bid is ending so
they played it in the meadow in the big
meeting that they get together I suck
your ween was part of it
there you go
[Music]
yeah Terry's got a new strategy with me
whenever he [ __ ] up he doesn't engage
with me on the air do you notice like it
is well I yeah he hasn't no smart he
Boyd's me Gary how does it keep
happening to me I know you're avoiding
my conversation here
um I mean I'm not sure what the answer
you want is I asked for somebody I trust
you're pretty well to send me the clip
who's always done well for me in the
past who kind of knows what we want I
said I just need a clip of this and I
wanted to get it to Beth as soon as
possible because she seemed to really
want it what she did all of that is
correct and I didn't listen to it before
I said it because you know that's not
make well you're saying it's not on you
you post another bug it's not because I
should have listened to before I sent it
can't argue with that
just wish she knew that yesterday why
are you in such a rush I mean what is
your rush
in other words like boy why couldn't you
take five minutes and listen to the clip
just to check it you know I really just
thought that it would be correct and
that was the stupid me to think that
hmm all right well you can't argue with
that you guys taking responsibility
right Robin yes he step right up and
start yelling stops here buck stops with
Bowie but I know I can tell you this a
shooter but I didn't what are you gonna
do I'm not a really good boss most
people just throw you right out and say
listen we'll get another job dairy has a
note on his desk that says slow down but
he hasn't slowed down yet one of these
days he's gonna take that advice
I think the note just is there any
ignores no listen you don't you know you
can slow down you can say all right let
me see what's on this thing before I
send it out
but all right look I'm thinking of
actually riding to slow down on Gary's
forehead make it a tattoo because then
he has to see it every morning when he
brushes those teeth right yeah yeah what
were you so busy with that you couldn't
listen to the five minute tape I'm
saying I wonder what you were doing I
mean I probably make it some calls and
you know all right well you're making
calls at least right Robin yeah you
tried your best though right as long as
you tried your best
oh you didn't he didn't try his best
it's no big deal you don't worry about
it just one more humiliation
[Music]